so i was in the discord server talking
to you guys by the way some of the mods
that we have are going back to work so
they don't really have the same kind of
free time they did before
so we've got applications opens for new
moderators make sure you guys go check
that out see if you want to be a mod the
discord server but i was talking to a
bunch of you guys and a lot of you guys
said
i should be checking out the joker solo
series where you guys said it was really
really really really good and i know i
haven't covered a lot of dc recently
largely because dc's not necessarily
resonating with me but i think maybe it
was just the beginning of the stories so
it's probably worth going back and
looking at the stories in terms of how
they've progressed and then deciding
whether or not i want to cover them
anymore but this joker story i'm glad
you guys suggested this this is like one
of the best joker stories that i think
i've ever read
right so here's a cool thing a lot of
this really comes out of joker war right
when joker just kind of unleashed all
kinds of chaos on gotham city and all
that kind of stuff and if you guys are
unfamiliar with batman up to this point
make sure you guys check out the link
down in the description
it'll take you to the batman playlist so
you can get caught up but the whole
thing about this is
that we kind of pick up here with
commissioner gordon and one of the
things that goes on is commissioner
gordon is basically at a top bar now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that is and i don't know if anybody
outside the states is familiar with that
but here in the states you largely have
bars that are considered cop bars in the
sense that
the average joe doesn't go there right i
mean you could
but you're probably going to start
getting funny looks when people realize
that you're not a cop right that's one
of the places where like only cops ever
really go there and a lot of them might
exchange
stories or kind of talk about cases
they're working and different things
along those lines but just kind of a
place for cops to kind of unpack
and then just do their thing right drink
or whatever the case is for commissioner
gordon i guess really former
commissioner gordon here now he's
retired but with gordon
talking to one of the guys who used to
work here this guy's name is danny ryan
right and he was a cop at one point in
time
and had long since retired the way it's
explained is that his dad had been one
of the cops that kind of came up during
the age of al capone right so like
you know the the saint valentine's day
massacre and that kind of a thing
but danny starts talking to gordon about
good and evil right about what it really
means to actually see a criminal and
when he looks at gordon he sees a guy
who's so young right he's like in time
you're going to start coming across guys
who are pretty extreme right and who are
pretty bad now
a lot of this is kind of told in
hindsight at the moment gordon is sort
of uh
is basically retired this is somewhat
early in his career and the conversation
as it goes on here is danny basically
tells them there's criminals out there
right there's guys who rob banks and
guys who kill people
and things like that like sure there's
criminals then there's evil there's
criminal other there's criminals who are
just on a whole different level now this
is really before
commissioner gordon has has really ran
into the joker
as we know it right this is still when
he's kind of working his way up the
ranks and what danny says
is there was a time early on in his
career when he ended up coming across or
was kind of working this case where he
basically saw what he considers to be
the devil right that he had been working
this case of this missing 17 year old
girl
and when he found her there was a guy
who had quite literally or was in the
process
of eating her face and he offered a
piece to danny ryan right and danny
just didn't quite know how to handle it
but he followed the rules of the law
right he did what the law told him to do
which was to draw his gun
and to make sure this guy gets arrested
and then he goes on trial and all that
kind of stuff and he says that's how
things work in an idealistic world
in the real world it doesn't work that
way he's like when you come across
evil you put a bullet in its brain like
you just do that and you don't ever look
back
and while commissioner gordon initially
dismissed that over the course of his
career he has learned there is something
in effect where there comes a point when
you will encounter individuals who are
just so heinously evil
the best thing you possibly can do for
society as a whole
is to really just kill him and in his
mind that's the joker and so what you do
is you kind of pick up the modern era
and what's called
a day and a day was basically this giant
attack on arkham asylum
and it wasn't necessarily one of these
things where like the joker did some
stuff and got away because the joker's
not locked up in arkham instead what had
happened
is 500 people had been killed in arkham
and the reason why is there's a couple
things happening
the first is a guy by the name of mayor
nakano who is really kind of given to us
as largely an inept person right doesn't
quite really know what he's doing
doesn't really understand what it means
to be a mayor in the city of gotham he's
really causing more problems than he's
actually solving but the other part of
this is that it all looks like it was
done by the joker that it was some kind
of modified version of the joker toxin
that basically spread its way throughout
the prison and then killed a whole bunch
of different people
but while commissioner gordon's working
this case and even presenting the
evidence to batman albeit with batman's
now limited resources
one of the things that he kind of hits
on here is things don't make sense right
something's not right
the joker usually always leaves a
calling card or something along those
lines the fact that this isn't there
seems kind of strange but at the same
time it really is just kind of the
joker's mo right to kill like 500 people
and just sort of call it a day and so
what you end up getting here is this
moment
where james gordon is just kind of
leaving and then you're sort of
going back and doing his thing and is
suddenly met by a woman by the name of
cressida right now she meets him in a
limousine there's this great big huge
imposing figure behind him right kind of
scary and she's like we need to have a
conversation about the joker right now
as soon as they end up getting to the
house that she's in
it's like this totally different
situation than what he was expecting
right what ends up happening
is we find out the joker is actually in
belize now that's one of the funny
things about his character the joker
whenever you usually see him in batman
comics it's you know the joker's assault
on gotham you don't really see the joker
in foreign countries but he is here
right he's literally in belize just kind
of hiding out there's a reason for that
and we'll talk about that here in a
little bit but the proposal that's put
forward by cressida here
is because of jim gordon's experience in
in hunting the joker and dealing with
the joker the kind of things that
joker's done to him right so like
injuring barbara gordon
turning his son james against him or
really kind of bringing his son james
down to the joker's level
taking what chance he had to regain
insanity and kind of wiping it away she
basically says
we have an idea right you have more
experience with him than anybody
else we want you to hunt the joker like
we want you to find the joker for us
in return we will give you a bank card
with unlimited funds
there is no limit and then when you're
done and you're back we'll give you 25
million dollars in your personal account
and then when he's kind of like okay i
mean
you just want you want me to you want me
to grab the joker and bring him in
for 25 million bucks that sounds like a
bounty and the the answer she gives us
no i mean that's not really what we were
shooting for i guess it kind of is a
bouncy to a degree but if all we wanted
was for the joker to be handed over to
the authorities we would hire the
authorities to do it we want you to kill
the joker the authorities are not going
to do that we can't hire cops to kill a
joker at least not publicly anyway and
we certainly can't do it with the
government right i mean maybe they could
maybe they can't but whatever the case
is
this has to be done discreetly right it
has to be done quietly and so it's one
of these things where he's a little on
the fence about it and then suddenly the
conversation that he had with danny ryan
the beginning of the story kind of comes
back again
when she asks the question do you
believe in evil and when the answer is
yes yes i do then in turn it's the
joker's evil we need you to take care of
him and so what you end up doing is
switching back over to belize
joker reading the newspaper and then
coming to this realization that
everything that's going on in arkham is
being made to look like he's the one
that did it right so seemingly the joker
doesn't really have a hand in any of
this and so following that you get a few
different things going on right first
you end up transitioning to this kind of
woman who's in this great big huge
incubation tank in santa prisca not a
whole lot going on there at least as far
as the revelation goes but then there's
also
other things like a brother and a sister
who basically get a kind of text message
right like another guy who gets a text
message
all these people are being contacted and
so ultimately jim gordon
meets up with batman and then spills the
beans now again one of the things to
remember about batman here
is batman doesn't have the same kind of
resources that he did because of the
joker war
it basically came to public life that
batman had been had been sending money
to like offshore accounts he had in
effect been violating like tax laws and
so in order to ensure those waters can
be navigated
and bruce wayne can maintain his role as
batman lucius fox effectively took over
control of wayne industries and so bruce
wayne doesn't have control of his own
company
at the same time they have to distance
themselves from him in order to
clear up all the red tape that was
basically dc kind of coming back and
saying okay
so like we're gonna separate batman from
like the whole wealth and all that kind
of stuff and take him back to his roots
of just being a pretty basic detective
with some incredible skills a really
really good
knowledge of like how to fight various
villains and like that's gonna be it
right we're going old school
is essentially what they were doing
which is great right it's a really
really cool thing and so when
when gordon meets with bruce he kind of
tells him everything that's going on
right the fact that he met with cressida
the fact that he was given or at least
promised 25 million dollars for killing
the joker and bringing him in
and it's kind of a funny thing because
where bruce kind of looks at this
and says like you really want to do this
don't you the response of gordon is
i do but there's almost this kind of
inner monologue that he has where he's
like i don't really want to admit that
out loud right like i don't want to say
yes i want to kill the joker because if
he admits it
it means it's something that he publicly
and really just fully desires
so long as he doesn't publicly say it
then at least there's some part of him
that can believe
that he doesn't want to actually do it
but the reality is this is personal for
gordon right like it's a very very
personal thing
and so he basically tells batman here's
what i need from you right i need every
single thing that you have on the joker
everything
everything everything i don't want any
of that stuff left out i want you to
have your people research this girl
and tell me what it is that you guys
know about her beyond that i want
access to your bat computer i want to
know every single file right everything
that's ever happened i want i want to
use your database
to fill in the blanks of what i have
with the joker because at the end of the
day commissioner gordon's knowledge
about the joker is nowhere near as
extensive as batman gordon needs that to
actually do his investigation
and to get all that stuff figured out
the other thing about this is
oracle is listening right barbara gordon
is listening and one of the things to
remember is commissioner gordon
doesn't actually know that barbara
gordon is oracle or even batgirl and so
you kind of have this bit of a of a
thing where where
you know batman's like oracle are you
listening she's like yes i just want to
go on record this is a terrible decision
gordon's going to give himself killed
but there's also a big difference
between what he's saying right he didn't
promise you that he would bring the
joker in
he just said it would make sense to do
it and that seems to be a bit of a
detail that batman actually missed
because it kind of catches him off guard
for a moment and then he kind of looks
at gordon like are you really gonna kill
the joker and that's when gordon pulls a
distraction
by essentially pulling this ace out of
the hole and just asking the question
are you sure you're just not worried
about your old man barbara gordon
and that's when the revelation comes out
jim gordon knows who knows that his
daughter is batgirl
and he knows that she's oracle he was
never supposed to know that he's
actually known
for a long time batman's lips are pursed
right he's like uh
and then like oracle's like what nobody
knows how to react to this right and so
at the end of the day like they end up
kind of having this this sort of meeting
with each other at least jim gordon and
barbara do and then ultimately you end
up just having jim gordon and really
barbara giving him information
saying obviously there's no way to talk
you out of this right there's no way to
convince you to not do this given the
history between yourself and the joker
this is very much a personal thing so
she gives him a phone and says this will
get you files to the
to the the back computer but know that
some of those files are locked and so if
you need access to those you're gonna
need a really really good reason i'm
gonna call you once a day
if you don't answer during that day i'm
gonna have the phone self-destruct right
he's on a very very tight leash here
which is not designed to curtail his
investigation to make sure he doesn't
find anything
incriminating on batman when he's
searching the computers it's because
it's her dad
and she's scared that her dad's gonna
die that's really what's kind of going
on there now as far as the joker himself
in terms of his location in belize this
is kind of a cool thing here and the
reason for that
is because this is kind of a safe haven
of sorts right now
why it's a bit of a safe haven again
we'll talk about here in a minute
because it's a really cool concept
that dc's never really explored before
but you end up having this guy desmond
who kind of shows up here and basically
says look like
the people you've killed in this
building you were not supposed to kill
right there's guys you can hit
and then there's guys you can't hit and
these are one of those guys
that you can't hit and ultimately the
joker's like don't really care man it's
kind of my thing
right to kill people it's just sort of
what i do and because of the fact that
this is not a mess that's easily cleaned
up
and because the powers that be are in
this position where it's the joker can't
be doing stuff like this
ultimately they ask him to leave in
response he's like but here's the kicker
though there's going to be
tons of people who are going to come
looking for me here and this is a
perfect spot right this is an actual
perfect spot to be
i can see everybody coming from a mile
away so i'll leave i'll get on the plane
and i'll take off get out of your hair
no muscle
fuss you can say you got everything
resolved the powers that be will just
kind of leave you alone and everything
will be copacetic but in the meantime
before i do
what i need is about 30 of your men to
basically help me ward off
everybody who's going to come here
looking for me now that's kind of the
question is
why are all these different people
looking for joker and who are the powers
that be
so we end up having cressida who
basically goes back directly to
you know the people who essentially
employed her only to find out that she's
essentially working for the court of
owls and the court of owls
are hunting the joker the girl who was
in the great big huge tank in santa
prisca she puts the mask on she's been
exposed to venom she's the new bane
essentially she's the daughter of bane
which is kind of a crazy thing and so
ultimately you have jim gordon who gets
on the plane and basically
heads out directly to uh to belize and
this is when you get this really cool
kind of explanation that goes on here
now
barbara gordon and like and you know
cassandra kane
and like stephanie brown and them
they're all looking into like cressida
trying to figure out what's going on
it's not a significant plot point
at this point in the story it's just
kind of a little background
investigation that's happening but one
of the things that gordon talks about
here is
a lot of the stuff that he kind of
picked up over the course of his time as
a cop but a lot of things that he also
didn't know and one of the things that
he talks about here
is that in the criminal underworld there
aren't necessarily
rules but there are norms right there
are things that you just don't do right
like when you're a criminal
you don't take out other criminals
unless they've done something to screw
you over
and there's kind of this unwritten rule
that's existed in comic books for years
and years and years and years and years
right it was it's always been that way
but this is one of those very rare
instances if there's ever really been an
instance at all
where like a comic book publisher comes
out that says here's the reason why
right here's some incoming book logic
for why that happens but you look at
things where like the joker teams up
with two-face right or like the green
goblin will team up with like loki or
something along those lines of mormon
comics and you'll have instances where
like villains will screw over other
villains and the question you always
find yourself asking is
why don't those villains kill the
villains that screwed them over and we
largely attributed that to the fact that
it's just well i mean the villains got
to stay so you can tell comic book
stories
instead the way this works is you don't
hit other villains
unless they've intentionally screwed you
over if you do then
whoever those friends and family of the
villain that you killed are
have every recourse to take you out and
nobody's gonna offer you any safe haven
more so than that the other part of the
way this works is that there are these
kind of networks right these safe havens
but back during world war
ii you had these places that were for
essentially german war criminals but
over the years they've been repurposed
and so the way this works is that if
you're a criminal and you're looking to
lie low you can actually go to these
places and you can
kind of just stay there for a period of
time it's going to cost you a lot of
money but you can stay there
and that it's almost kind of for
criminals and ran by criminals but there
are rules there much like where you
can't hit other guys you can't
take out other criminals you can't just
start tearing the place up right it's
kind of a huge sign of disrespect
and ultimately you'll be ousted from
those places more so than that the
reason why the joker's being allowed to
stay at
that base in belize is kind of bragging
rights if they let the joker stay there
and the joker follows the rules like
he's supposed to which
we know the joker is not going to do
that and the joker eventually goes back
to gotham then those organizations or
criminals or people who were in this
particular instance desmond the guy who
runs it can basically kind of advertise
hey
we kept the joker saved from batman
imagine what we can do for you right
that's the kind of marketing they can
put out there and so you have
commissioner gordon who lands in belize
with some terrible spanish which is
probably still better than mine and
starts talking to all these different
people who are here
and he kind of gets his nose to the
ground he does a little bit of
investigation and the very least that he
can get is that there is this place
out there in the in the countryside
where like criminals go whenever they're
looking to lie low but they don't say
the name of it right just for fear the
fact that there's eyes and ears
everywhere and if they start talking
about this place there's a good chance
that they'll end up being killed
because no one's supposed to know that
it's there but ultimately jim gordon
figures out where the location is
now not knowing the joker's here
jim gordon goes knocking on the door
saying hey uh you know i'm i'm looking
for somebody right he kind of hears
this this this answer like uh who is it
and he's like i'm looking for someone
like i'm looking for an old friend the
door opens and there's the joker
and joker's like jimbo is that really
you
[Laughter]
gordon immediately pulls the gun it's
the last person he was expecting here
the problem is he's surrounded by like
30 guys right so
guns get dropped joker and commissioner
gordon kind of start talking while
that's going on you got a brother and
sister murdering team that shows up here
now
these two actually hail from a family in
texas and that's why
like literally the daughter of bane is
hunting for the joker it's why these
these this brother and sister are
hunting for the joker
because bane was killed in the assault
on arkham asylum scarecrow was killed in
the assault on arkham asylum the members
of this family of the the brother and
sister were killed in the assault on
arkham asylum
specifically one of their members of the
family had actually taken the rap for
the rest of the family and then in turn
was just serving life there they
kind of funneled money and arkham to
make sure they could serve the most
comfortable life sentence possible
but it's basically just revenge
everybody thinks the joker did this
so everybody's coming for the joker and
that's kind of the funny thing because
like literally joker's like hey man you
got here just in time
because everybody's coming here to kill
me so draw your guns
chat it's gonna be a long night
[Laughter]
and so what you end up getting here is
this really really cool moment where you
have like the daughter of bane who's one
of the first ones to come running up on
the joker and try to assault him
now the joker kind of dodges out of the
way but she may she she gets
through his guys so fast and then
ultimately gets her hands on him with
the intention of just like
killing him the problem with this is
that as soon as she has her hands on the
joker the twins arrive in a bus they
hijacked and
killed everybody on board right just cut
all their throats so now they're like
we're gonna take out the joker too
and then a little bit of beef kind of
happens between them and
and the daughter of bane which is just
sort of like okay so like who are we
gonna kill like like who's who's gonna
kill the joker
because the daughter of vayne is like no
he's coming back to santa prisca so we
can deal with him we can execute him
there for what he did to
to bane and then in turn the twins are
like nope he's coming back to texas so
we can kill him right
joker stops everything and says hey guys
so let me know if you've heard this
right what's white and black and red all
over he's like it's the nerve gas
canisters that i spent the last few days
planting around the ground
i painted them that way you know for the
joke beep
boom like the whole place explodes right
like nerve gas canisters
ever just go off everywhere right
everybody's dumped with enough nerve gas
to knock
them out cold it's the most joker thing
ever right it makes perfect sense why
not set this place up so that you can
kind of have your own
your own sort of backup plan right just
rig the whole place to detonate and the
reality of this and that's what's so
funny about this the reality of this is
he's violating the the criminal norms
all over the place right you would never
do this
in one of these facilities but let's be
honest with ourselves what are they
gonna do the joker is quite possibly the
most
dangerous criminal in the world
depending on who you're talking to
some people might say deathstroke but
what separates people like deathstroke
and joker is the joker is the most
extreme
sociopath right he's not a psychopath he
takes satisfaction and killing others so
he's an extreme
sociopath right like that's his whole mo
and because of that there's no real
moral compass there outside of whatever
it is he wants to do
in order to achieve his own selfish
goals in most of those instances
it's getting batman to come after him
but because of that the joker will kill
whoever he can
whenever he can if it means it's gonna
draw batman out everybody in the world
every single person who lives in the
world as far as the joker's concerned
with the exception of batman is just
cannon fodder toys to be used in the
game that he plays and that's what i
think makes him the most dangerous
criminal in the whole world but
ultimately
commissioner gordon wakes up and when he
does of course you end up seeing the
joker basically sewing the mouse shut
of one of the guys and he's kind of
talking about how like this guy and his
sister think they're super dangerous
they're not
right he's like you know they're young
kids they don't understand what it's
like gordon they don't know what it's
like for us old crowd see we're
old school we know how to do things the
right way and that's one of the kind of
one of the funny things here is because
there's almost a kind of connection
between these two right because the
joker and jim gordon really are kind of
old school right like
we know how to get work done right these
young kids they don't they they're
they're
they're all pomp and circumstance right
they're putting on a show
but when it all comes down to it their
guts are made of of of liquid just like
everybody else right like they're just
they're weak they're half measures and
that's kind of the funny thing because
he's like
let's sit down and have a talk gordon
right old school man
to old school man the guys who knew how
to do things right he's like i
understand
that you hate me gordon i totally get it
i totally i totally get you hate me i've
done terrible things to you
right i destroyed any chance your son
had of ha of sanity i shot your daughter
through the spine
she's gonna be paralyzed and for the
rest of her life and has to have an
implant that allows her to walk around
and her days are numbered right like i
have turned your life
upside down and he says you know in
looking at you
you're so intriguing because let's look
at batman right
batman's crazy batman's a lost ball and
high weeds the logic this man follows is
i'm going to dress as a bat and beat up
criminals in the middle of the night
no sane human being would come to that
logical conclusion he's
crazy he's as crazy as i am and if it
wasn't for you
grounding him he would have lost his
mind a long time ago he'd be serving a
life sentence an arkham asylum
basically just the kid who lost his
family and then went nuts and that would
be the story of him
and he says but you gordon you're a
hypocrite right like
you are a person who believes that
fighting evil
makes you good maybe good and evil do
exist but just because you're fighting
evil
does not mean that you're a good person
evil fighting evil so at the end of the
day
tell me why you do this right like why
don't you let batman just
kill everybody why don't you just take
the reins off of him just say you know
what bruce do your thing
why don't you just cut him off right and
just let batman go off the deep end so
this quote-unquote war could be won and
the response of gordon is
because this is a war that cannot be won
it's the inner thoughts of commissioner
gordon right like this whole
conversation
is basically gordon publicly admitting
to the joker that at the end of the day
batman's actions really are not getting
anything done and that's what the joker
says right he's like the whole purpose
of batman is he busts some criminals he
hands them over to the justice system
the justice system puts them on trial
they go to arkham asylum and they escape
that's how the system works and it's
working as intended the system was not
designed
to eliminate criminals the system was
designed to enable criminals why
because if the blue collar criminals the
guys who rob banks and things like that
if they're doing making all this noise
over here then that's what the
prosecutors focus on
because that's what people worry about
people don't worry about the guy who's
committing
fraud out there in the ether somewhere
with a white collar job they worry about
the person who's gonna break into their
home
it's a great distraction right keep the
people looking over there and you do
your thing over here the system works
exactly as intended so why do you play
this game
why do you do this right like why do you
fight evil and believe you're the good
guy
in the first place knowing that just
because you fight evil does not
automatically mean that you're good and
the response of gordon is interesting
here right he says i don't know
that i know how to be good but i do know
that i know how to fight evil
and that's good enough for me and so
that's kind of the funny thing because
he says okay here's what i want from you
right here's what i want from you gordon
i want you to figure out who's the
person behind this because i want you i
want you to tell me i want you to run
this investigation i know that you've
been sent here
to kill me and you're gonna go back to
gotham city and you're gonna get 25
million smackaroos
and that's nice but i want to know who
it was that killed all those people in
arkham asylum and then made it look like
me and the responsible warden is it was
you and that's when the joker freaks
one of the important things to
understand about the joker it's a matter
of pride right like the joker is one of
these guys where he's like yeah man i
kill people all the time but i
want people to know it was me who did it
it's not as though i'm an assassin
i'm not somebody who sneaks in your
house in the middle of the night kills
you and then leaves he's like
is there anything about me that would
lead you to believe
if i was going to unleash a joker toxin
in the entirety of arkham that it would
kill people in their
sleep is that really what you think i
would do no i would unleash the joker
toxin in the in the in
arkham asylum and yes it would kill
everybody there but i would
love to know the satisfaction that the
person at the other end of the hall was
just laying there
in terror as they heard each person in
the cell next to them
succumb to their laughter and then
ultimately die knowing that creeping fog
of terror is making their way towards
them i find satisfaction in that gordon
i
love that gordon what in the world would
make you think that i wouldn't do that
and that line of logic right there is
absolutely sound because while the joker
is crazy as hell right
as well he's absolutely nuts that's
exactly what he would do right the joker
leaves
calling cards the joker wants people to
know the things that he does
he's an extreme narcissist and sociopath
that's his whole mo
and so it's like i want you to figure
out what's going on because there's
something much bigger of foot going on
here something much much bigger that's
taking place here and he's like i want
you to see something gordon you have
this
faith in a in a system right you have
this belief this little tiny spark in
you
that believes this this judicial system
this criminal justice system that you
work for
is actually capable of doing the right
thing i want to remove that i'm going to
snap that out of you
and i want you to understand gordon i'm
going to break you in a way that's
stripping you down naked and showing
pictures of what i did to your daughter
will will simply not do right i did that
to you in an amusement park right i had
you go through this roller coaster ride
of hell where i showed you pictures of
what i did to your daughter of what my
guys did to your daughter
i'm gonna do far worse than that of
course that being a reference to the
killing joke but it's one of these
things where he's like in the meantime
go find out what's going on right like
find out what's happening here and so
ultimately he just kind of leaves uh
leaves
commissioner gordon on his own he heads
to what's basically europe and then
commissioner gordon is saved by the
daughter of bane and
and and as they have this not really a
lengthy conversation here she recognizes
him of course and says like you're bane
from gotham city right and he's like yes
and she's like go home gordon right
you're already drowning in the darkness
head back to light while you still can
gordon this
is this is a land of wolves and you were
not meant for this world right you were
not meant for this kind of an
environment i understand that you have a
desire to be i understand that you want
to do the right thing
but no there's a big difference between
people like you who do what they can
and people like me who do what they have
to but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you